SALLY HOROWITZ: My name is
Sally Finkelstein Horowitz
and I come from Poland.
I was born in
Zwolen, A small town.
And when the war broke
out, I was 11 years old.
And on September 3rd,
the bombs came to Zwolen,
even though it was not
a industrialized city.
And then when the
bombers flew away,
the place was a
complete like a inferno,
complete and engulfed in fire.
And I was scared, because I
couldn't get to my parents.
And then after this, the
Germans, the planes came again.
And they were spraying the
people with machine guns.
And then we were in
the woods overnight.
We survived that.
And then when we came back
home, everything was bombed out.
And we just huddled
together in little rooms
with whoever we could.
And then, there was the ghetto.
We were all carted to
one place of the city.
And it wasn't a big
town, but they still
brought in from different
small towns people.
And everybody was
in the same place,
sleeping wherever they could.
It was terrible.
Then they were patrolling
us all the time.
And sometimes the Germans would
knock at the doors at night,
and say, "Ich bin ein
Arzt," I'm a doctor.
And if there were girls, they
said they have to inspect them.
They weren't doctors.
So they made a little
hole in the wall,
so we could run out and hide.
And there was also a
synagogue in our town,
which I cannot forget,
because it was--
the paintings were
on the ceiling,
and there were very thick walls,
and the doors were very thick.
And I was always in
awe of that synagogue.
I always felt like it's
a very holy, holy place.
Well, this was burned down.
And when we went in the ghetto,
my father and my little brother
went out to hide in a village.
And I somehow refused
to be in the ghetto.
I just always wanted to get out.
So one time I went
to visit my father.
I was very, very
close to my father.
And all of a sudden, I
was sitting, and I feel--
I see somebody standing
there, so I picked up my head,
and there was a
man standing there.
And he says to me, "Who are you?
Who did you come to visit?"
Because they knew who was
supposed to be in the villages.
And this was a Polish man.
He was the eldest
of the village.
And I told him I came to
visit the Jewish people.
So he started to yell,
"Are you Jewish?"
And I say, "Yes."
He says "You wait right here."
He's going to bring
me to the Germans
for coming out of the ghetto.
And I ran across the street.
I became friendly with
one of the girls there,
the Polish girls.
And I told her what happened.
And I told her, "I'm scared."
So she said, "Come with me,"
and we went up in the attic
to hide in the attic.
I remember my heart
was pounding so bad.
And she was laughing.
She says, "Don't be scared."
I was scared.
I was the Jew.
So he kept asking everybody,
"Where's that Jew?
Did anybody see that Jew?
Where is the Jew?"
But nobody told him anything.
So they went to look for me.
Of course, that's when he
started to scream and holler
where I was.
And then when he
went away, I started
to run and look for my father.
And I was scared.
My little brother was, at the
time, about six years old.
And so my father
says, "Don't worry.
I will give him
a bottle of vodka
so he wouldn't bother you."
But meanwhile, I was scared.
Now, we were in the
ghetto for a while.
I don't know.
It must have been a year or so.
And it was horrible.
They were always
taking us to work.
And they took out the
rabbi, and they make him--
they made him walk on,
uh, the Sefer Torah.
They would pull his beard.
They were pulling his beard
and blood was coming out.
And, uh, nobody helped him.
And then every other day,
there was something else.
We were sleeping and all of
a sudden we heard the church
bells, and trumpets, and bands,
whatever they did, "Juden,
heraus, alle Juden heraus."
And we all had to get out
and meet in the market place.
And there was a lot of
shooting and a lot of hitting.
And then they made us
march 12 kilometers.
And for some reason,
a certain person,
the people we stayed
with in the ghetto times,
one of their
daughters got married.
She was 17 or 18.
And she was pregnant.
And we were walking the 12
kilometers, and she was--
until I had my own children, I
never thought of her too much,
but I can't forget her.
She was very big.
She must have been in the
eighth or ninth month.
And it was very warm.
It was the second
days of in September,
it was a holiday, Sukkot,
the second day of the Sukkot.
And she wore her
father's trench coat.
And her feet were very swollen.
And my mother had,
um, some water.
She always used to give
out a little bit of water.
And then we came to
the train station
because Zwolen did not have
a train station at the time.
And we all sat
down on the ground.
And we were joined by people
from different smaller cities
and ghettos.
And there were
trains in back of us,
we all sitting on the ground.
There must have been
10,000 people or so.
And we could smell like
chlorine from the trains.
But we didn't know this
was going to be for us.
And while we were there, one of
my sisters, a few days before
was taken to a farm, which was
a few kilometers from my home
town.
And I don't know, for some
reason, one of the Germans
was walking by where I was
sitting, and he pointed to me.
And I said-- no, he was looking.
And I got scared.
And my mother made me bend down
and hide myself behind her,
because we didn't
know what will happen.
So he passed by
again, and he pointed
I should get up,
and come, "raus."
And my mother pushed
my other sister.
This was her fear, "go, you'll
have to take care of her.
She won't be able
to wash her hair."
This is the last
words I remember.
And they took-- he took
out about 21 women, girls.
And then everybody
started to run.
Everybody sensed
something wrong.
And there was a lot
of shooting, and a lot
of beatings and the shootings.
And we were walked another
three miles to the farm
where my sister was there.
And we worked there
on the potato farm.
And then when it got cold
and there was no more potato
picking, they took--
picked out-- we were a hundred
people there, men and women.
So they picked out
again about 35.
And I was one of them, and
my sisters, my two sisters.
And we were sent to Skarzysko.
Skarzysko was worse than
any concentration camp
you can imagine.
It was an ammunition factory.
And the first thing what greeted
us were people with yellow
faces.
They were all yellow.
They worked with some
chemicals or something,
and they were
exposed to, I guess
the whatever it was there.
And they were all
terribly yellow.
I was so frightened.
I remember, it was terrible.
And then, we were sent
to a different part.
And we weren't there more
than about two, three weeks,
and I got very sick
with the typhus.
We worked in a factory,
an ammunition factory.
Now if you stayed
back, they shot you.
So you had to go every day.
They used to wake us up very
early in the morning and count.
There was the
counting, the counting.
The countings, to
drive us crazy.
And then when we got to the
factory, we were counted.
And then when we came
back, we were counted,
constantly the counting.
And they had those beds like
in four layers, no straw,
and no nothing.
And then people
were getting sick.
And I had typhus very bad.
My hair came out completely.
And there was no
food, naturally.
They gave us a piece of
bread, which wasn't bread.
I don't know what it
was, ersatz of some kind.
It was one once a day.
And once a day we got some soup
which was like dirty water.
So when we were
sleeping, they would,
um, they would woke
us up one time-- no,
we were walking from
work through the gates,
and they hung a
person in the gate.
So they hung-- we had to look
at that person for three shifts.
And, um, this wasn't too
far from the um, latrine
where we had to go and we
had to run every night,
a few times during the night.
And he was hanging there.
And somebody took off his shoes.
He had some shoes on.
They took off his shoes.
They must-- he must
have been there
for about three or
four days or more.
So nobody should miss him.
So all they saw him.
There was no food and,
uh, the beatings--
I still have a scar on my
leg because we were standing
and counting and counting.
All of a sudden, they decided
to hit us over the heads.
And I figured, I'm not going
to get hit for nothing.
And I just wanted to crawl by,
so I ripped my leg with the--
with the wire.
And I was bleeding, and nobody--
they didn't have anything
to put on my leg.
And it started to
spoil very bad.
And, uh, so when
we worked there,
there were some Polish people
coming into work from the city.
So one woman said, uh, to
put sour milk on my leg.
Maybe it will go away,
because it started to swell,
and, uh, it was bad.
So we hid--
I managed to hid my
mother's ring in my mouth
when we went in to the ghetto.
Not the ghetto, to the camps.
So we gave her the ring and
she brought in a loaf of bread
and, um, a little
cup of sour milk.
So the three of us decided
what to do, to put it on my leg
or eat it.
So we decide to half on my
leg, and half to eat it.
Now if we wouldn't
be the three of us,
we would, we would
never survive.
None of us would have made it,
because we were watching out
for one another.
Put us on trains to go
farther towards the west,
so we went to
Czestochowa, another, uh,
ammunition factory.
Somehow the Russian armies
came too fast for them,
and in '45 we were liberated.
And the feeling, it's
a terrible feeling.
While you in camp, you don't
know what tomorrow will bring.
But what made me go is I
thought my father was hiding
in a village with
my little brother,
that he will survive there.
And I always, I was very,
very attached to my father.
He was, was over 6' 4".
He was beautiful person,
and a beautiful human being.
And I thought he'll
survive there.
And I always thought
he'll need me.
I'll, I'll have to help him.
He'll sicks, oh, like
I am and he needs help.
This what made me go.
And in order to--
it's funny, I'm thinking
of that now that, um,
how I split myself.
That it wasn't me there.
It just wasn't me.
I was somebody else.
It wasn't me.
And, but unfortunate,
when we, the war ended,
we actually afraid
to leave the place.
It was a very funny
feeling, the three of us
were sitting holding hands.
We're afraid to go out.
Finally, when we did
go out, we found,
we found something
terrible, like nothing.
And, uh, and the natives
weren't too friendly either.
I went back home, and uh,
to look for my father.
So naturally they--
I came to the city.
There were already a few people.
And they told me that my
father and my little brother
was turned out to the Germans.
Well, anyway, so
it wasn't too good.
We had to get out of Poland.
And I went back to the land of
Germany, would you believe it?
I felt safer in Germany.
Only because there
were the Americans,
I suppose, we felt safer there.
And, uh, of course, I
came to the United States
and I met my husband here,
and we have three children.
And, uh, every
time, this is when
I became pregnant
with my children,
I-- it just like I woke up.
I got terribly frightened.
And ,um, every time I thought
of that woman, Rachel.
Rachel Goldfarb was her name,
what happened to her baby?
What, uh-- she was very
close to having her baby.
And her face is
almost in front of me.
What did they do to the baby?
What they do to her?
And here I am.
And I did have the
children, because, uh,
I always said if, um, that's
what Hitler would want to, we
shouldn't have any children,
or we shouldn't-- we just
disappear.
So my children I named after my
father, my brother, my mother,
and my sister.
They always question me, because
you know, the old story, "Where
our grandparents?
Tell me about--" They were very
curious, very bright children.
"Tell me about your
about our grandparents.
How were they like?
And what was your
hometown like?"
I have like a panorama
in front of me.
I could be in a room
full of people, and um,
if-- there was a time
when I was, let's say,
in Skarzysko I didn't--
I didn't talk at all.
And, um, I just, I just
couldn't believe it.
I just didn't talk.
And then I was constantly
talking after the war,
because then I realized
I, I was afraid.
If I won't talk,
I'll see everything.
And even now, when,
um, when I vacuum,
or I do some tedious
household thing, I always cry.
I always see-- because
I could be at that--
with 100 people.
And if I sit quiet, it's
just like a panorama
with all that stuff
coming through my head.
Nobody's left.
And we were always--
my house was always
full of people,
because all this time it was
my grandmother was with us,
so everybody was
coming to my house.
And, um, so I always
think about those people.
And I'm always
afraid that I'll--
I don't have any
pictures of them.
And then always wonder about
my little brother or my father,
because the two of
them were together.
You always say,
"How did they die?
What happened?"
It's something you don't forget.
And, and the horror
of it is, every time
I see the newspaper now, and,
uh, with Nazis, and how they--
it's just that it never ends.
It's no end to it.
And this frightens me very much.
And I'm not trying to
show to the children.
I don't want to scare them.
The-- the men who already,
you know, grown people.
And uh, I'm scared.